do you know this one they used to say
Portland didn't have good musicians they
were saying Portland where is that who
do you know in Portland that's ever done
anything I say I know me and I'm having
fun I'm Chris funk I'm a musician in a
band called The Decemberists and I'm on
a journey looking for the most
surprising and extraordinary people in
music my next stop takes me to the soul
of Portland
there I'll meet your ol Thomas the
Pacific Northwest Godfather of rhythm
and blues
my town of Portland Oregon isn't known
for having a thriving RMB seen but the
Portland I know has a secret hidden in
the heart of the city's music culture is
a master of soul who's shared the stage
with the likes of Otis Redding and James
Brown this established 78 year old is
proving that great RMB can be found
anywhere my name is Yael Thomas I'm
singing with a band called the pain we
have a very unique style of rhythm and
blues
I've been R&B musician for over 40 years
and I've lived in Portland all my life
[Applause]
girls music has taken him as far as the
Apollo Theater in Harlem but after
experiencing great achievement the siren
song of Portland lured him back home we
met him at his place known for its
infamous Sunday jam sessions with some
of Portland's best musicians Portland to
me it's a very positive place so I come
back home where I know that I'm positive
and I figured like maybe I can do
something in Portland to help musicians
I really have enjoyed sharing my soul
there are no words to explain that
feeling it's like magic
Ural has played music through
segregation and the civil rights
movement watching Portland transition
into the city it is today the Pacific
Northwest was very segregated there was
a lot of places about you know black
singers and stuff couldn't go so then we
had opportunity to show the people what
music was really about it wasn't about
being divided we didn't have no black
and white because we all did it together
[Applause]
[Music]
I've played with some very amazing
people in my life like Mick Jagger Otis
Redding Carla Thomas wonderful people it
was a blessing for me to have all the
experiences that I can say that was a
part of your old musical journey has
taken him around the country but I'm
happy he's made his way back home to
Portland because every city needs an
unexpected treasure I'm back home now
with the most wonderful group that I can
ever deal with the guys are called the
pain and we're gonna bring it
[Music]
[Applause]